Salut c'est Alain Rey,
Bienvenu dans cette nouvelle vidéo
Oh putain j'vous ai pranké
Les amis bienvenu, ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait une petite vidéo
Ma barbe... ELLE A DISPARU ! (pleure)
C'est une longue histoire, qui explique aussi pourquoi j'ai un suçon sur le nez
Qui n'a pas été fait par un humain, calmez-vous tout de suite,
ni par un animal calmez-vous encore plus !
Vous saurez le pourquoi du comment de ça dans environ deux semaines, je ne vais pas vous spoil
Mais aujourd'hui on n'est pas pas là pour parler de ça on est là pour parler d'un FanGame !
Souvenez-vous il y a 9 mois pour être exact.
On avait fait une vidéo sur un fangame où un fan s'était amusé à faire vraiment un jeu avec une petite histoire c'était hyper cool
il avait modélisé ma maison et ça m'avait littéralement bouleversé parce que c'était hyper réaliste .
Vous avez maintenant deux secondes pour deviner qui m'a envoyé un mail hier !
Yo Squeezie, ça y est, c'est aujourd'hui plein d'émotions
que je t'envoie cette version finale du chapitre 2. J'espère que ce nouveau chapitre te plaira et qu'il plaira à la communauté
Donc je vous rappelle que dans le 1, en gros
Il y a des gens qui me faisaient revenir dans le passé pour fouiller ma mémoire en pensant que j'étais mort mais je n'étais pas mort !
Donc je revivais moi même vraiment mon passé , bref ...
Après qu'ils aient essayé de te ramener dans le présent, l'inconnu te guidant au travers du talky a étrangement réussi à les stopper
Mais celui-ci vient de se faire enlever sous tes yeux par quelqu'un que tu connais bien.
Tu te réveilles perdu dans le temps. Comment en est-on arrivé là? Qu'est-ce-qui a pu provoquer tout ça ?
Seras-tu capable de sauver Jumbo? Retrouver l'homme au talky, voir plus, sauver le monde ?
Bon avant ça tu vas te faire éclater une bonne dizaine de fois ! Sorry Sorry
Le mec met les points sur les "i"
C'est parti
*Elle arrive !*
Qui arrive ?
(Rires)
C'est drôle (Rire) !
La putain de lampe.
Cyprien avait raison, la prophétie s'est réalisée.
"A fucking Squeezie Day" Benjamin ! Wouuuuh !!
Ok ça joue...
Chapitre 2 - Les origines..
Alors on est dans le laboratoire Squeezie voilà je possède, actuellement mon propre laboratoire
Ca c'est un employé à moi bien sûr Clément tu as très changé.
Il m'a dit de regarder un peu partout car il y a des petits détails à ne pas rater.
Administration
Skyyart.. et un stagiaire
Personne connaît son nom...
Jiraya à ce qu'il parait (Rires)
Dr Mickalow avocat commis d'office
Le premier qui vient me faire chier pendant une de mes parties d'Overwatch / pendant que je travaille
sera reçu avec un coup de pied au cul
Et mais, et Micka reste tranquille même dans les jeux Micka il fait le mec (Rires)
Regarde le là, ce putain de Mickalow, ils
l'ont fait avec une bonne calvitie
Tu sais c'est ce qui t'attends dans quelques années Micka!
Jumbo notre sauveur (rires) ça va super loin!
Le Grand JD, expert botaniste
oh la la, il a calé des potos
DR Nozman, scientifique de l'année
McFly et Carlito, on ne sait toujours pas ce qu'ils font dans cette entreprise
(rires)
Rappel: Ne pas approcher cet individu
Coiffure pouvant varier
Tétons pressurisés type 10 millimètres
Corps de lâche
Taille : 170 cm
YES ! Il m'a respecté, ça ça me fait plaisir
Le 169 cm il est plus là mon gars,
Big Flo et Oli en concert
Oh la petite pub, pour Big Flo et Oli, calmement (rires)
Il s'est gavé mec
Oh Shit. OH SHIT !
Oh merde je suis québlo non non je vais
crever
oh putain ça va partir en fight, si ça
part en fight mec j'ai un pied de biche
Et crois moi on va pas faire de
mécanique ou d'enfonCHage de porte
D'enfonchage ? J'arrive plus a parler.
Oh putain tout est parti en couille
Et ça va!
Il m'a agressé putain il sait que je suis nul...
Oh oh... OH C'EST HULK ?
Yes ! Oh putain de fils de chien
Putain
Pardon excusez-moi
Je vais crier pas mal hein je vous préviens d'avance
Mais il m'a fait peur aussi
Oh...
Fils de chien
Yes!
Putain mais va falloir que j'ai du skill en fait je peux vraiment crever là!
Mickalow en lendemain de soirée quand il a trop joué.
Moi je me casse
On va pas chercher l'embrouille avec l'espèce de petit alien de merde la on s'en va d'ici.
AH ! What the f*** ?!
Oh, putain enculé...
J'ai plus de vie mec il me reste que
40 hp
Alors où faut que j'aille là?
Ah c'est fort !
J'ai peur
Il y a eu des pas...
Il y a des pas, il y a un mec
Oh, c'est la lampe!
Vous l'avez vu ? C'était la lampe !
Mec, on va devoir aller voir hein!
Mais il est con? Ca va exploser...
*explosion*
Ah c'est fort! Ah putain..
Ahh, là il y a un conduit, faut que je prenne le conduit.
OK, nouveau chapitre
Bon, on a eu un gun
On a eu un gun mais on va économiser les balles
Quoique, on en a 34, à mon avis....
Oh merde j'avais oublié les touches
DAMN IT!
Oh putain...
Tu entres, tu meurs ici c'est chez moi
verrouillé par carte d'accés, merde
Je passe par là...mauvaise idée
J'ai peut-être tiré beaucoup trop de balles par rapport au monstre que c'était
mais je me suis chié dessus ok?
Ils t'observent...
D'accord...
En tout cas ils ne savent pas mettre d'apostrophe hein, ça c'est... Ca c'est clair !
Il y a un téléphone qui sonne
Yes ?!
*Haaaa.... Squeezie....*
Ouais?
*Pour ouvrir le bureau...*
*Cherche ton signe astrologique...*
OK!
*Je te vois Squeezie.....*
C'est cool, tu es une personne très glauque!
*Aujourd'hui tu crèves...*
D'accord et pas sympathique en plus!
Il faut trouver son signe astrologique pour ouvrir un bureau, ça n'a aucun sens
Déjà ça veut dire que tous les mecs qui sont nés que..euh... sur la même période que moi
peuvent ouvrir mon bureau.
Pour moi c'est verseau si jamais.. alors cadavre... Cyril
Hanouna.. non, furoncle, non, squeezie flèche avec un caca
ouais déja, déja respecte moi putain
C'est ça la, qu'il faut trouver là. ça, c'est verseau ça. Sur les colis y'a pas un verseau?
Un verre d'eau ! Peut-être c'est un jeu de mot ! Eeeh non !
Bon les amis je galère trop, vous savez  quoi on va l'appeler directement. Ah bah c'est pratique hein
d'avoir le numéro du dev' du jeu. Oui !
*Bip*
*Allo?*
Ouais vieux c'est Lucas. Ça va?
*Ouuais ça va et toi?*
Bieen, écoute je trouve pas mon signe astrologique
*Tu trouves pas ton signe astrologique?*
Bah je sais ce que c'est mon signe astrologique, mais je le trouve pas dans le jeu.. sur les murs. J'ai chercher partout !
*il faut que tu ailles.. Partout ?!*
Partout ! Est-ce qu'il est bien sur un mur ou pas du tout ?
*C'est bien sur un mur, c'est bien sur un mur..*
Putain ! J'ai échoué, je suis dégoûté .
*Moi j'ai pas envie de t'aider la hein!*
*rire*
*Le début*
Vers le début, ok. Bah écoute je me démerde et au pire je te rappelle si besoin
*Bonne chance*
Merci *rire* Putain il est génial en plus ! Je suis dégoûté , je suis en train d'échouer les amis là putain
AAH IL EST LA ! NON !
Par contre je sais pas ce que je dois faire
Merde. Peut-être que ça à ouvert le bureau en fait
Attends on va voir. Et peut-être qu'il y à des nouveaux monstres, ça m'étonnerais pas, on va se méfier on va prendre le gun
Prêts à tirer rompopopom tel Rihanna attention !
T'es vraiment.. Benjamin je vais t'appeler je vais t'en mettre une, attention !
Alors le bureau, est-ce qu'il va s'ouvrir ce bâtard?
YES, I'M MOTHER FUCKER . Alors il y à quoi dans ce putain de bureau..Carte d’accès
Ok maintenant je sais ou il faut aller, c'est cette porte là! *Bureau Docteur Decroix spécialiste de la survie en milieu hostile*
*Entrée interdite, car il est vraiment taré...*
Mais mec.. (m'en bats les couilles frère) Faites demi-tour ou mourrez
Ouais mais mec c'est la sortie du jeu, je peux pas me barrer
Dernier avertissement, mais non, mais mec? Mais je suis obligé d'y aller ?
AAH !
Non mais y'a eu un problème
Bah ouais mec !
OH Putain !
Ah il m'a vraiment flingué ! Oh merde
y a un truc à faire en fait faut que je trouve quoi faire
Merde merde merde merde merde
je pense qu'en fait faut juste que je me baisse si je me baisse je meurs pas hein normalement
NOOON !
Comment j'fais ?
M'en bats les couilles je rappelle Ben
ça m'énerve
(musique)
*biiiiiiip*
*rire* (il doit en avoir marre)
Me dis pas que t'as toujours pas trouvé ?
Si j'ai trouvé ! Ce que j'ai pas trouvé c'est comment échapper
aux fusils à pompe des mecs  bourrés
ah j'ai vu ok excellent
merci à très vite je dois tellement le décevoir
le pauvre ben il se dit, mais putain
ne pas faire un jeu pour un mix et d'en faire un fossé que je pauvre
alors on est bien là
mais qu'on a un pont que maintenant c'est lourd ça
Yes I
oh non, oh merde
y a un truc à faire
mais c'est chaud
à
mais tabarnak mais s'essouffle aïe aïe
ça